Jürgen Drews plaudert aus dem
Nähkästchen bei Pixum zum Beispiel
über seine Begegnung mit dem Logo
Ferrari ihr wisst schon
unter der Dusche und was er diesen
Sommer mit Daniela Katzenberger auf der
Mainau Khalid hat Prozent da ist er
nämlich aus allen Wolken Prozent
gefallen so was hat er glaube ich noch
nicht erlebt eine
lustige Geschichte für uns zum zuhören
für Green Wave glaube ich er hat sich
ein wenig geärgert hat ich den Eindruck
aber Pröll wird selbst und es geht um
das selbe sein Kindern Prozent dass er
nicht so ganz einfach ist Prozent er hat
er zwei Kinder aus man muss sagen zwei
Epochen Prozent ja auch eine
interessante Geschichte das und viel
mehr jetzt im Interview um wenn ihr mehr
sehen wollt Prozent oben hielt in Arbon
ihren warten
über dem Video nicht vergessen 2
klicken und ansonsten bis dann Blatter
dpa
ca
herauskommen was geht
Herr sauber der Tür oder Kette
dass Schröder
Gefährt
er sieht gut aus
Wetten Waldbad
das sagte Blatter wenn dafür eine halbe
Million
AMA ich hätte eigentlich am 20 Toten
der Experte aber wenn sich Ulrich Rathe
das Wahlrecht weil er aber in der ich
kann es nicht
es hat niemand wurde Meister
beigebracht den Gottesacker nachgesagt
wird es genau um Stimmen
August im Internet Kontakt hatten der
gestrige
Jürgen wie ist die Lage
Duisburg es gab
drei Kameras Hallo
diese ist ich bin die Wunderkerze
höchstpersönlich
ich bin Peter Schaar
ein Gitter schade eigentlich gar nicht
passt
diese Marotte denn ich werde gleich in
Köln auftreten
auf dem Oktoberfest in Köln und das ist
einfach nicht mein Ding
aber ich kann mein die Leute
finden es sind die Haie
windig Party machen auch ein
Touristenparadies geschadet der Schwede
erlitt Dearborn
hier wurden bereinigt der jetzt auf
Promotionstour werden
promoviert was auf Promotionstour
aber man muss ja auch nicht so oft nicht
abergläubisch
unser Profil
wenn die Poren Prozent
haben die nicht mehr 4 Wien
ich Liebe ich meine
riesengroß sein
hier nicht stehen» hieß es der FC St
da wohl zweifelsohne eine
Arnd Wunderkerzen brennen
für einen Sieg ich Rede nicht und das
SN APA dpa erst
Pater Flynn
Partie
Bild 2 und runter
ist wieder gegen das seit 14 Wochen
Nummer eins ist
vor Alguersuari Toro ausgemacht Schlager
Berater ist das Kraut ist die erste
Single
pop-diva einig dass der der Motor jetzt
überschlagen Back to the Roots werden
Back to the Roots wäre wenn ich jetzt
warum haben armer armer Aprilia 0
wegen der Jahre wurde es ein bisschen
anders
«Wenn ich jetzt etwas machen würde
Meyer ist
in USA gemacht aber wenn er NT achtziger
Jahre
darunter Bargeld
ja richtig es ist nur
Jahren Rock mit Popp einschlagen war
aber auch in den Charts
und meine ich Ernst und l
an warum habe ich nicht weitergemacht
Frage an mich
kann ich sagen meine Frau ob Prozent
nicht am oder seiner Breloer
hat mich
wenn du so willst Verlass ist driftet
auseinander welche die wahnsinnig
beliebt dieses diese Frau
und unser Sohn
allgemein Sohn an aus erster ehe
der gerade 30 geworden ist und jetzt
aber wieder wehrt sich jetzt aber wir
gehen
richtig an
um hast du Lust am 29 mehr Lahn
anzukommen so was machen normal es sei
wieder bergauf gehen
Martin h ist nicht tragbar
auch auf der steckt seine Nase das ist
schon seit Jahren in Musik gemacht mit
dem Lied hätten
in Bonn hatte ich in Berlin schon
richtig großen Namen geborgt
das hat der Verein Verhältnis zu seinen
Kindern
also die Jahreszeit geschiedenen Ehen
kommen
wie Tim Wiese seine patchwork-familie
aber ganz anders als man sich vorstellt
weil österreich auf 2 gebrochen
Jahreszeit auch
besteht ja
an so zu parieren wir haben uns
immer geliebt
wir legen uns auch heute noch weil wir
sind uns auch in vielen Sachen
unheimlich ähnlich
das sagte auch meine ex-schwiegermutter
Dr
die sagte «Du glaubst nicht wie
ähnlich darin suchen dir ist
wir hatten aber zu Schwierigkeiten
eine ehe
die auseinandergeht
wo es Querelen gibt wusste
Schwierigkeiten Verwerfungen gibt
die auch die Briten
nicht alle versucht
irgendein ich bin also sichtlich
die Koreaner
so harmonierte er es nicht Leben lassen
die haben überhaupt keinen Kontakt
miteinander was sehr sehr schade ist
weil ich eigentlich
immer ist versucht
aus diesen verschiedenen Pachuca Kölker
Elemente nie
einen Nukleus zu schaffen oder Haftungen
guten Kontakt zu Corinna
ich selbst habe ich einen guten Kontakt
habe ich weiß natürlich
um im mit diesen ganzen Bewerbung»
o-ton ich bin das ist
wenn sie nicht den ersten Schritt machen
würde
dass sie auch so harmonisch zugeht
dass es dann nie wieder Werte das ist
sehr sehr schade weil beide zusammen aus
Unternehmen Behörden und der Hand auch
wenn sich ein Verein verlassen
darunter Teil so seltene
sehr sehr gelitten
und ich kann mich deswegen nicht
zerrissen weil ich mit meinen Sohn
wieder
sehr gut auskomme
und Prozent ein
wir wollen nicht ist ja schon auf
Mallorca
m zusammen
nur ein zwei Wochen sein
und jetzt auch mit meine Familie dann
zusammen
er hat nicht sollen sein weil ich meine
Idee diese Tragödie hat
immer weiter machen musste und
im TT
ich mit der Zeit im Verzug kam und dann
hat mich richtig Zeit gekostet
es lag ein bis eineinhalb Monate
in der Produktion sich für die Katze
gemacht haben ja für Daniela
Katzenberger
die sie dann aber abgelehnt hat
und wie ich jetzt für USA weitermachen
werde Prozent wäre
Juli
Herr Wulff gleich mal sagen wenn er als
Nebensatz nur bei einer Katze nämlich
dass man den Weg an die sind die Comics
weit gefehlt die kann singen
die weiß wie sich vor Mikrofonen
hätte leicht entzünden jahrzehntelang
macht dick macht es ärgert sie das
nicht mehr
um aber nicht immer Mater wissen dass er
bis dahin gestellt
dass in Leverkusen Erfurt
und sie kann singen sie durch hätte
b aber wie ich meine das ist ja aber ist
so
der ERC Paulo oder der ist mir selber
der Mund offen stehen aber er kommt Neid
nicht zusammengekommen was
Samaras Künstler geschaffen
Juli in warum weiß ich nichts man
sollte seine Strategie werde sie hat
sich immer noch nicht geäußert
Problem diesbezüglich nie gegeben
ich finde sie den Titel wirklich alles
auf einmal obwohl sie
in Sierre es wunderbar mit Bravour
gesungen hat und
danach merkte dass ich damit
beschäftigt hat es uns Wert ist den
Pfälzern den ich konnte und Prozent das
hat ihm mit Bravour gemacht
und beim zweiten Durchgang
ich muss sagen ich hätte das Ding nicht
so schnell oder gesunkene vehement
und er ist hier wirklich gut
man habe aber der Platz ist so aber
ausweiten möchten sagte ich weiß ich
nicht
obwohl sie schon gesungen aber so extrem
teuer hatte
das ist aber dass sie ausmacht
warum ist Daniela Katzenberger Daniela
Katzenberger bist du denn schon meinem
Besuch stinksauer sein eigentlich
die Kommission hat die Forward hat und
geben sagte Lüscher sie mich nicht
gerade jetzt meint seine Reaktion also
wäre ich nicht da wo ich jetzt an der
Länge des Weges regiert wird ist
wir sehen das erste nicht überleben
werden würde
Glasscheibe am Mischpult
sie sind den ersten Durchgang
seit der Nähe
Hallo
Szabo
dass man sich wirklich etliche
aber sie noch normal eine Version durch
weil dann kann man immer noch sie passt
sich noch besser oder sind das also da
the Track dar und so
und erwiesen so oder so schnell schafft
sie habe ich viel mehr Zeit eingerechnet
Hallo
sind das zweite mal
und ich glaube dass Modern zweiten Vers
sagte Obama
durch heissen ich nicht
so ganz trocken ja jetzt bist du Pech ja
ich singe
11 8000 Prozent sagte Rosen
so sei es ähnlich
Schweigen im Walde
ich bin dankbar denn es ist nicht nix es
kamen am Nachmittag dann die Eröffnung
ihrem Land
Kammer ein die einzelnen abhänge
die Leute stehen da sie nicht
Bau dir ein Schloss
dass er in Nürnberg erlebt
ich Wette mehr die Welt entdecken
Sängerin
sie hatte Mikrofonen Hand
aber man sagt ins Mikrofon «Ich muss
auf Klo
Prozent
das Erwitt erreichte mit der Geige
geradeaus Seite 6 erstens das Tableau
derartige sie lachend zurück
das ist auch Carla
am 8 wir gehen jetzt in die aber lachte
der Reha
Dollar aus mehr
so alles wunderbar
es war die Eröffnung von meinem
Nachbarn» mehr
am nächsten Tag
ich mach da die auch schon auf die
Bühne singen auch weiß begrüßte
Leute davon dass er eine Tochter und
Wasser waren
wirklich coole voneinander
wir hatten von der Kanzlerin gehört
mehr pm Lingen das Geld ist da dann
testen sie uns Lichterketten
während werdende von der Katze gehört
so war meine
sie würde Feuer an ob man sie kommt wir
also erscheint so gleichzeitig aber
Jahren gehören will
mehr das habe ich bei meiner Nase
und ich habe es satt Gebirge Mannes
wurde so Demmer Richtung BSC wenn man
merkt dass bis 18 Uhr Station gewesen
sein
das was sich die mir mein Coach Laurenz
aus
denn ich kann mich wieder in vollem
Umfang
von Björn Mehlhorn entfernt
bisschen länger waren
Bill zurückgekommen David für die
Stützung 7
wenn ich dann gleich anfangen
die Abendkasse die Kasse ist ja was bei
der Kasse
der war erst etwas variiert
ich sah wie die Kerzen dabei werden die
Kanäle
ja wo sie jetzt sind es schon über
Unwohlsein
Jörg Butt steht II haben einen am
Kreisel da der Konsum ein Reiner Witz»
Alican t in Wien sind
sie widerstehen
die Leute drum rum Gabriel wurde
vermisst Rebekka halten
Kerner Teams Fotografen Druck
wieder in die Kabine logischerweise der
Daniela
so ganz unvoreingenommen
Danielas ist die schnelle Mann erhoben
dass nur kurz das Ambiente
neben Ende
Nein Hallo
Zettel dann lass das mal kurz in den
Zebrastreifen gehen
Winnenden Fieber schaffen kann
sagte Hainer
Kanäle
die Bilder schon haben quasi mehr
lol das ist doch ein Manko ist dahin
die Freunden immer sehr an ihr
festgehalten
dachten gar nichts
Kuttnig müsse an wir sind ein bisschen
langsam
sein Danila
das ganze Leben
also was ist denn los
ich kann mir sehr viele Leute mich
ertragen
Hallo
dass es das im Laden aufgemacht
und dass der so genannten Wirklichkeit
ein Tier
weil du einfach
teuer ist
wie üblich Dips
unerwartet wollen
ich Kriege dapd
Klasse sowie hat sie zwar nicht gesagt
also über die Platzangst
seither kam
ich will er gar nicht angepasst
dann ist für Gläubige ich hab meine
dar
nur das was
Nein Nein Nein
ich sagte Nein
die Leute erwarten das von mir
und wir erwarten das von dir wenn wir
nur einmal so in den bei dreien Schweiz
noch die Resonanz so du bist du bei dir
wahnsinnig positiv
ich hab auch schon wird das nicht gerne
Autogramme Gefühl das mache ich nicht
auch nicht immer gerne aber es muss
das muss doch wirklich sein
die haben doch irgendwo
in Anführungsstrichen
dann Rechte auf
die Leute
bei dem wir erste ich doch so durchlebt
die doch so dar
da sagte sie nur
ich muss nur 1
ich muss noch Klo gehen
Danielle
dann geht es jetzt auf Klo und statt
aber wohl Schick ich dir nach
den Teenager zu
dass das bin dem Buch in Deutschland nun
ist bindend
ab 1 als 2 lerne ein bisschen
respektvoll zu sein
ansonsten für alle sagte Ebadi
aber da war ich wirklich sauer nun ist
das Tischtuch ist zerschnitten die ANWR
wir haben sie nicht
ob er Frieden schliessen Diarra
es ist wie in einer ehe
Dr
Appel
dabei spielt die Frau hatte um ihn herum
die ganzen Canadiens Unicom Prozent ja
wo ist der Kirchentag hat sondern er
Sepp Maier
sie wird geweckt irgenwann das Buch
studierten vom Kläger das aber genau
erzählt
okay
wer aber ist alles halb so Wild dass
Watson lustig
das Projekt ist dann auch wieder
würden sie es tut
Rumors an die Amerikanerin
wie etwas kolportiert wird er sich
verselbstständigt
ich hätte
Tipp tierisch sauer auf sie wollten ihr
nie mit ihr nie wieder was zu tun haben
und dass er das unmöglich so überhaupt
bestimmten
Viechtach das ist heute kein Platz
und sie es hat geklappt
in anführt aber trotzdem mit sich im
reinen ist ich hatte meiner Karriere
nicht mehr
der Prozess gegen Barca nicht gegeben
während das paar das in den Worten
«Ich mach mein Leben wollen Kerzen
und die Richter nicht dann gehen
wollen
wir waren bei dem Thema Prozent der
Bürger so sagt Voss zu wenig Zeit für
die Familie
es wäre ein Novum war aber bei der
Frage zerreißt sich dass der Preis pro
Jahr geöffnet waren veröffentlichte
Zeit hast du deinen Sohn Lebenspartnern
zu gehen oder ich bin schon wieder was
zu Unternehmen oder oder oder
das aber wenig das macht mich ein
bisschen gedrückt das liegt aber an mir
selber
weil die Zeit hätte ich mir nie
du könntest es machen die Heiligkeit
aber
ich bin irgendwie ein komischer Keks
ich eine Schnur lange vor
die Matinee zu schnappen aber sowas gibt
jetzt hat am 8
auch noch nicht richtig
fertig was macht dass der Brief nicht
das weiß ich nicht allen Gasthäusern
Bammers Ergebnis mehr müssen wir
darüber diskutieren
einfach als gegeben
das ist eine gute Idee
Reisetermin das war's
das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen sagt ob
weil ich mit dem ihnen schwer aber eines
kann ich dazu sagen
ich aber ich bin
weit gefehlt also würde sagen wir sind
verwaist mehr Zeit mit seiner Familie
als viele andere
vielmehr zeige ja
aber auch die Mario Kart Zeit diese
Sorte Jahren
montags
jetzt die Sammler vielmehr zu Ende weil
ich jetzt auch auf promotion-tour bin
für einen Titel wo sich um in der
nrw-liga hin die Wunderkerzen brennen
und die Sterne nicht mehr die
kommenden Wochen geben
siehst du hören sie ist für die
Melodie ist eingängig aber und Georg
Klein Wettbewerb
ich bin in einen Konter den alten Charts
da ist es Zeit
knappen zehn Wochen im Eis
Hallo aber was sind die Gebiete aber
gehört
die hat er ja
wenn die jungen
das belegen
Candy bekannt wurde ein Lasso raus
Wegberg Attacke
die beste APA APA
leider war
wer wie auch immer
und es so Frage ich immer zwischendurch
in Eisleben Main absolutes haben
und da muss ich sagen ich bin glücklich
dass ich auch mit diesem Hobby Geld
verdienen
produzieren ich produziere fast nur
Flops
aber egal immer wieder was er so alles
ihren
und es darf ich mal kurz verraten als
ich anfing
quasi noch bei den Happy Singers sein
jetzt Francine bei der Wehranlage 6
Haspe Mannheim geboren erzählt mehr
Wallenhorst
Prozent das war die Sängerin und
Komponistin Thermometer sogar sehr viele
ist die Gemeinde richtig es ist ja meine
Therapie ich möchte das Vertrauen der
CIA also wer selber Probleme bekommen
habe b
erste Meldungen über ist alles
wie auch immer
diese hatte Sängers haben zum Beispiel
eine mitgemacht
unter anderem ja reagieren
wie ich auch nach produzierter werden
auf der Bühne sind wenig auch mit den
Happy Singers heute noch
vier sind wir noch daran wie aktiv noch
hin und wieder auch auf der Bühne
erscheinen
«Ich sage dazu betreutes singen
wyg Marvi Marmara MoMA Marmaduke
Mama Mama Mama eigentlich nicht genannt
ja und wie und
m
und die
also ich sag ja Bonn ich meide sowieso
überwältigt vom Mai mein Gesang
Wunderkerzen Sunniten und Hass auf
wir müssen das in der Wildnis entlassen
ja das würde ich wohl erst Anfang er
habe am Abend noch ein paar Sachen das
Opfer gab als
ich war sehr Jung ist sehr sehr wichtig
an der Elbe ich muss nur eines ich muss
nicht mehr am Montag 9
du nicht du kannst du am Ende muss man -
Autogramme geben
Nakba 8 80 Nein ich
schreiben sie gerne alles was sich
bewegt
ich habe in Wien
war ich in dieser Klamotte guckt euch
das noch mal an
in Wien mehr erste Oktoberfest
das über Pakistan
ich habe gar
also suchten die Kulthits geschrieben
ich weiß gar nicht wieviele
ich habe heute noch mal zum Professor
Doktor einer Mann den ich sehr gut kenne
sein Fall vor dem aggressiv mit ihrem
Team machen ist ethisch Air One
fusioniert
allen voran
diese
du siehst immer nur von 'den
die Brüste
Vorsicht auch Schichtarbeiter Erpressung
gewann
die Systeme von innen das ist einfach
darf ich mal ganz kurz für ein Jahr
Antony Jahren
Tja und dann hast du nicht nur die
besten
ja du hast recht ich würde am liebsten
auch sehen
bei Sunrise sie haben wir schon immer
noch natürlich war berichtet zum
Geburtstag vor einem Jahr wieso er sich
auf den 1 wie hätte er gern warm up at
a Glance stürzte Aktien die auf die
Bühne
neben einem make-up wird und sich
entwickeln wird
aber danach schreit dass über Bord
schweißtreibend «Es bleibt eine kleine
Kinder spielen
die Athleten auch gar nichts zu tun
ich übernehme ein tabu was man da
sowieso machen
okay an vielen Orten
mach dir das mal
nach Nissen OKE ich möchten
keine Frau kennenlernt nach einer
Schönheitsoperation von dir
das Thema erlaubt vier Semester reichen
nicht
die Windverhältnisse er
epd erschreckt wird er genau Weseloh
verladen
leider kann ich sehr gut kenne ich ja
auch nicht mehr zählen Müller
weil die Nachfrage in der Kirche
man habe meinen Kopf weil sie da Red
weil die pc-welt aber mein Kopf will in
der Küche HB Essen als
wichtige Dinge nicht umsonst das ORF und
die wenigen Wochen erst hatte
Persona Non grata
mittlerweile Bolton Godard akkreditiert
er b ich sage dir was er arrivierte
Wiesen Schlager
wenn die bunten Blätter in Samarra es
aber ist es wirklich da gilt es in der
durch das Internet ersetzt werden soll